[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview faut
aujourd'hui nous sommes en compagnie
d'anne soupart écrivaine théo d'hygiène
bibliste catholique
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
2008 vous fondez le comité de la jupe
pour lutter contre la discrimination des
femmes dans l'église après que le
cardinal andré vingt-trois interrogés
sur leur rôle dans la célébration des
offices a déclaré le plus difficile est
d'avoir des femmes formées le tout n'est
pas d'avoir une jupe mais quelque chose
dans la tête 12 ans plus tard début 2000
20 vous postulé à la succession du
cardinal barbarin comme archevêque de
lyon une double provocation parce que à
la fois dans l'église catholique on
n'est pas candidat à cette fonction
c'est le pape qui choisit ensuite parce
que seul un prêtre peut être évêque est
donc un homme votre candidature a très
peu de chances d'aboutir alors pour
quelle raison la proposer expliqué nous
parce qu'il y ait un plafond de verre
qui empêche les femmes d'être pleinement
reconnus dans leur propre église
les femmes sont très actives dans
l'église catholique et docu quantité de
fonctions mais elles ne sont jamais
parfaitement responsable il ya toujours
un prêtre qui les supervise et elles ne
sont jamais autonomes dans leur dans
leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière par leur
propre église
donc il est temps il est temps de dire
que l'église ne peut pas fonctionner sur
un seul de ses poumons
elle ne peut pas marcher sur une seule
de ses jambes
l'église doit être faite d'hommes et de
femmes et il est temps que ça change et
c'est pour cela que ma candidature
intervient alors vous n'êtes pas la
seule puisque à un nouveau bond fait
mine east semble souffler sur l'église
catholique puisque dans votre sillon
sept autres femmes viennent tout juste
de proposer leur candidature à des
postes réservés aux hommes
évêque diacre prêtre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut être catholique
et féministe facilement ça n'est pas
facile ça n'est pas facile parce qu'il
ya un discrédit de principes posés sur
le mot féministe on dirait que c'est un
mot
cherchez d'ondés négatives alors que
c'est simplement la reconnaissance de
son existence d'être féminin dans une
société qui qui traite tout le monde de
manière égale bon donc le mot déjà est
difficile et puis la propre attitude des
femmes et est extrêmement complexe et
beaucoup de femmes sont complices du
système qu'il est kim et discrimine qui
les écarte et elle adopte le discours
masculin qui les oppresse donc la voyez
il ya un énorme travail de
conscientisation des femmes à fournir
pour qu'elles se rendent compte qu'elles
sont libres d'avoir leurs propres
paroles et qu'elles ne sont pas obligés
de répéter le discours que les hommes
leur un style tout doucement dans
l'oreille c'est ce que vous souhaitez
dénoncer on le comprend avec votre
candidature c'est cet autre candidature
est-ce qu'il s'agit aussi d'ouvrir la
discussion quant à cette distinction
possible entre sacerdoce et gouvernance
et donc l'ouverture aux femmes des
fonctions de gouvernance de
responsabilité oui c'est très important
pour moi parce que vous veillez dans
l'église catholique toutes les
responsabilités de gouvernement sont
pensés à partir des prêtres
seuls les prêtres ont des charges de
gouvernement et je voudrais à la suite
de ce qu'a demandé le pape françois
lui-même
je voudrais que soient distingués la
prêtrise et le gouvernement
les prêtres sont prêtres ils ne sont pas
ils sont peut-être doué pour être prêtre
ils ne sont peut-être pas doué pour
gouverner donc je voudrais que cette
distinction progresse dans l'église pour
le moment il n'existe pas et que des
femmes effectivement puisse être nommé à
des postes de responsabilité tout en
restant laïque certaines voudrait être
prêtes certaines préfèrent rester laïque
pour ma part je considère que je suis
une laïque une baptisée et que mon
baptême suffit par le baptême tous les
catholiques sont prêtes prophète et roi
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une
reconnaissance
de leur pleine capacité à exercer ces
trois fonctions de près de prophètes et
de roi donc je suis capable par mon
baptême je n'ai pas besoin du ministère
ordonné et quand j'ai candidaté à
l'archevêché de lyon je les fais tout
une forme laïque parce que je suis marié
je suis bien comme l'aï juste je
souhaite rester laïque et c'est à ce
titre que j'ai candidaté alors dans les
sept candidatures que nous avons proposé
aujourd'hui il y a des positions
différentes il y à une femme qui est
déjà prête et qui a été ordonnée par un
réseau de femmes régulièrement ordonné
dans les rangs de la succession
apostolique s'est allié en ligne
continue depuis les apôtres et elle
milite pour une une fonction de prêtre
mais de manière à ce beaucoup beaucoup
plus incarner que la prêtrise actuelle
beaucoup plus proche des gens beaucoup
plus en partage d'égalité dans une même
communauté pas en situation de surplomb
comme le sont les prêtres aujourd'hui je
respecte sa position ce n'est pas la
mienne mais ça n'a aucune importance nos
candidatures reflète notre diversité et
je dois constater que parmi les sept
rames qui candidat à part celle dont je
viens de vous parler
aucune ne souhaite être prête l'une
souhaite être évêque l'autre nonce
apostolique c'est-à-dire ambassadeurs du
pas une souhaite être prédicatrice
laïque et quatre autres souhaitent être
diack
c'est à dire dans le service dans le
service ordinaire des précaires des
marginaux
donc vous voyez que la fonction de
prêtre est en crise
et quand je le veux le dire de manière
un petit peu triviale jeudi le dieu met
en crise
il ne suffira pas d'y mettre des femmes
il faut réfléchir en profondeur à ce que
c'est qu'être prêtre aujourd'hui dans la
société de 2020 et je demande à mon
église de réfléchir aux réformes qu'elle
doit apporter à ce ministère de prêtre
alors certains de vos collègues un
théologien
reconnaissent l'importance de poser la
question de la place des femmes dans
l'église mais ils jugent
contreproductive
votre méthode que leur répondez vous je
leur réponds que c'est typiquement une
phrase qui leur a été soufflée par par
la domination masculine actuelle
contre-productives pourquoi pourquoi est
ce que ce serait contre-productif on me
dit que c'est contreproductif parce que
cela clérical liseret les femmes c'est à
dire que ça les rendrait complice d'une
situation qu'elle déplore martin actuel
le cléricalisme c'est l'abus de pouvoir
des prêtres bon mais pourquoi est-ce que
ça l'ait cléricalisme
comment faire autrement que de
candidater ce qui existe avec une telle
position
eh bien on ne fait rien on attend que le
système s'éteignent de sa belle mort ce
qui peut durer 20 50 100 ans et on ne
fait rien voilà et moi je suis une femme
d'action
j'entreprends je pose des gestes et je
considère que ceux qui parlent ceux et
celles qui parle en disant c'est pas
comme ça vous fait vous devriez vous y
prendre autrement eh bien je leur dis
mais fait
allez-y que proposez vous il vous est
reproché aussi une forme
d'instrumentalisation notamment lorsque
vous appelez des non-catholiques 20 des
non chrétiens à vous soutenir une
pétition en ligne a d'ailleurs reçu
quelques 6000 signatures d'anonymes
comme de personnalités à l'image de
cécile duflot s à l'opinion commune de
se prononcer en dehors de réflexion
théologique
alors d'abord ses 16 mai seize mille
signataires de la pétition pas 6000 sauf
si je vous ai mal entendu alors dieu
merci le catholicisme est universaliste
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas que les
catholiques qui ont le droit de donner
leur avis sur ce qui se passe dans le
monde catholique bon catholicisme est
ouvert et je considère que ce qu'on
appelle un peu rapidement des non
catholiques ou des gens non croyants
d'abord on ne le sait pas toujours
personne ne dit qu'ils sont non croyants
ou non catholiques
simplement qu'ils sont à distance de
l'institution actuelle mais vous savez
dans les sondages il y à 60% de français
qui se disent catholiques et il y à
moins de 3% qui pratiquent en allant à
la messe
une fois par mois c'est donc déjà pas
beaucoup donc ma question est la
suivante comment écoute ton les 57% qui
ne vont plus à l'église mais qui se
disent catholiques et bien moi je
revendique de pouvoir parler à ces gens
là et je revendique que ces gens là ont
des choses à dire sur le catholicisme et
ils l'ont dit pendant des années
et petit à petit n'ayant pas été entendu
ils sont partis sur la pointe des pieds
parce qu'ils étaient lassés de ne pas
être entendus donc je considère qu'ils
ont le droit à la parole est ce que le
risque de la provocation n'est pas aussi
de heurter de crispées les positions des
uns et des autres de radicaliser
peut-être aussi certaines postures et
donc d'empêcher tout dialogue
écoutez je pense que ce que vous appelez
une provocation qui n'est pas le terme
que moi je reprendrai c'est plutôt une
main tendue à l'église je pense que ce
geste qui est effectivement qui paraît
un peu fou est un geste qui permet de
réfléchir et de faire bouger les lignes
au contraire de faire évoluer
regardez comme sur la question de
l'homosexualité notre société à bouger
en moins de dix ans et bien moi je crois
que la petite phrase une femme
archevêque a mais après tout pourquoi
pas je crois que cette petite phrase
peut progresser dans les consciences
même les plus hostiles et que petit à
petit elle fera son chemin dans les
consciences et qu'un jour on dira mais
bien sûr comment at on pu refuser que
des femmes deviennent évêques et cette
man que vous tendez à l'église comment
est-ce qu'elle ait reçu ce que vous avez
entamé un dialogue avec les plus hautes
instances de l'église
écoutez nous n'avons pas eu de réponse
à la fin je n'ai pas eu de réponse à ma
demande ma candidature d'il ya bientôt
deux mois
je n'en ai pas eu ni du nom ce qui est
pourtant chargé de recevoir ces
candidatures ni de la conférence des
évêques français donc je le regrette je
le regrette parce que cela témoigne
d'une absence de compréhension de ce que
ça peut apporter un débat un dialogue
une une vraie conversation même si
l'église n'a que ce mot là à la bouche
elle entre en conversation avec le monde
mais si elle refuse d'entrer en
conversation avec les simples femmes qui
peuplent son église
mais comment va-t-elle y arriver voilà
donc c'est dommage que l'église n'ait
pas répondu
mais de si de là j'ai des réponses
individuelles d'encouragement est en
tout cas de mapa je vais toujours au
devant des prêtres que je rencontre ce
matin nous avons été à la messe à la
madeleine pour présenter les sept femmes
que nous avions qui candidatent pour les
présenter à la bénédiction du seigneur
et à la fin de la célébration le prêtre
était là je suis allé le saluer et le
remercier de de ceux de nous avoir
gentiment accueillis ça me paraît une
démarche normale
je pratique beaucoup plus la main tendue
que la volonté de refuser le dialogue
que je rencontre parfois autour de moi
vous restez avec nous à une soupe en ont
fait une courte pause en prolongeant
notera la discussion dans un instant à
tout de suite
[Musique]
est de retour dans la grande interview
nous sommes en compagnie d'anne soupa on
s'intéresse à la place des femmes dans
l'église catholique en soupe est ce que
vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui il ya un an
tu reçois masculin dans l'église
oh bien sûr bien sûr il ya un autre soit
masculin les femmes les femmes on ne les
voit même pas on ne le salut pas
toujours on les ignore bien sûr qu'il y
a un an tu reçois masculin et vous voyez
dans la question des abus sexuels qui
est tellement grave actuellement dans
l'église c'est cet entre soi masculin
qui a favorisé les dérives et surtout le
silence parce que soyons clairs ce qui
est reproché à l'église
les abus sont très graves mais c'est la
dissimulation de ces abus au lond années
aidant et encore d'année ça a été
insupportable à l'opinion publique
nationale et aux catholiques eux-mêmes
qui ne comprennent pas comment on a pu
faire à on a pu être embarqué dans un
contre témoignage aussi fort bon et la
dissimulation
elle est due à l'antre soit masculin de
l'église catholique
comment dénoncer un confrère comment
dénoncer quelqu'un avec qui on a des
relations qui en général a beaucoup de
talent qui est une personne
charismatique qui a une très belle aura
autour de lui
comment le dénoncer déjà comment
accepter d'y croire alors après comment
le dénoncer à la justice apparaît
impossible et il n'y a encore d'autres
affaires qui sont en encore en sommeil
que et que nous allons apprendre dans
les semaines et dans les mois et dans
les années qui viennent donc la chose
n'est pas fini et j'ai toujours dit que
lens reçoit masculin avait favorisé les
abus et je continue à dire que plus il y
aura de femme et moi il y aura d'abus
parce que les femmes introduisent une
différence vous voyez quand vous vous
êtes dans un groupe de personnes qui
vous ressemble eh bien vous avez un
phénomène de mimétisme qui se produit et
l'autre c'est le même que vous mais
quand il ya quelqu'un de différent et
bien vous n'avez pas la même attitude
vous êtes beaucoup plus
capable de dénoncer de dire à cette
personne ce que tu as fait ça ne peut
pas durer il faut aller la justice bon
et bien les femmes auraient permis ça et
l'absence de femmes la roupie et ça fait
très très grave parce qu'on le rappelle
en vous ne candidate et pas n'importe
quel archevêché vous candidat ou
candidate et à l'archevêché de lyon qui
est gravement entachée par l'inaction
d'archevêque successifs en forme et
d'affaires de pédophilie dans quelle
mesure est ce que les femmes auraient
elles pu empêcher ces actes de
pédophilie est-ce qu'elle pourrait
comment pourrait-elle régler le problème
si elle était au poste de gouvernement
alors déjà je crois qu'elle aurait elle
aurait empêché la dissimulation tassé
déjà l'essentiel bon empêché les actes
même c'est un travail en profondeur
beaucoup plus compliqué c'est un travail
sur soi qu'il faudrait que les prêtres
mène dans le dialogue avec des noms
prêtre entre entre des communautés qui
acceptent de se parler et effacer la
mixité qui peut il faire équipe et y
conduire c'est c'est l'acceptation de la
parole de l'autre bord il faudrait
encore il faudrait que ce monde qui vit
à part accepte de vivre comme tout le
monde et une disposition serait très
importante pour ça ce serait de mettre
un célibat optionnelle c'est à dire que
ceux qui le souhaitent deviennent
prêtres mariés et je pense que là il y
aurait un état d'esprit beaucoup plus
conscient de ses responsabilités et est
beaucoup moins prompts à la
dissimulation et même aux actes de
pédophilie on se souvient des
révélations l'année dernière concernant
des agressions sexuelles commises par
des prêtres contre des religieuses vous
dirais que là aussi c'est un climat
incertain rapport de force qui a permis
ces situations situations qui sont
dénoncés aujourd'hui car la parole se
libère aussi dans l'église il y a un
réel changement de comportement de la
part des femmes il faut effectivement
que la parole se libère du côté des
chats et l'abus les abus sexuels
perpétrés contre des religieuses sont
effectivement le signe d'une emprise
d'un pouvoir exercé par les craies
parler clair sur des femmes qui à qui on
a appris que obéir et servir le christ
dans l'humilité c'était leur consigne
majeur pour leur vie de religieuse mans
et enfreindre cette consigne
d'obéissance pour prendre du recul et
pour dire mais non ce n'est pas normal
je dois refuser de telles privautés je
ne peux pas laisser faire ça bon que ces
femmes prennent déjà conscience de ça ça
a été un pas important
bon il faut bien vous rendre compte que
l'emprise ça nous paraît toujours
surprenant quand on est à l'extérieur
mais c'est quelque chose qui arrive très
progressivement une touche après une
touche un pas après l'autre et c'est
très petit à petit que l'on sombre dans
l'emprise et une fois qu'on est dedans
c'est très difficile d'en sortir parce
que on a été complètement enveloppé par
cette emprise et c'est une la libre
décision n'existe plus on est on est
devenu la chose d'un prédateur bon donc
il y a un énorme travail a fait je pense
que nous ne sommes qu'au début
les religieuses ont un énorme travail à
faire autour d'elle par la parole par la
formation à la résistance à l'emprise et
nous devons demain avoir un corps de
religieuses qu'ils soient assainis de
tout c'est de toutes ces humiliations et
de toutes ces distorsions insupportable
les femmes au pouvoir dans l'église
c'est ce vers quoi vous tendait à quoi
est-ce que cela ressemblerait ce qu'il
ya une approche féminine de la religion
parce qu'il existe des femmes pasteurs
chez les protestants qu'apporte-t-elle
de différents dans leur approche de la
religion
alors que nous qu'il y ait des femmes
qui veut y accéder au pouvoir
j'en suis bien consciente mais il faut
savoir que dans l'église catholique
officiellement le mot de pouvoir
n'existe pas en peinture de service man
et c'est vrai c'est très bien et on a
tendance à dire aux femmes ah mais vous
vous voulez un pouvoir alors que quand
ce sont les hommes qui exerce ce pouvoir
aimer bon parce qu'il devient un service
comme par enchantement
donc je voudrais déjà récusé le fait que
le pouvoir exercé par des femmes soient
plus mauvais que le pouvoir exercé par
des hommes
alors qu'est ce que ça changerait qu'est
ce que ce serait qu'est ce qu'il y
aurait de différent et bien il y aurait
justement la différence il n'y aurait
que ce pouvoir est partagé entre des
hommes et des femmes et que la mêmeté
c'est à dire le fait de se voir en
miroir à travers l'autre qui serait
hommes avec hommes ou femmes avec fabien
n'existerait pas parce que nous serions
continuellement confronté à l'autre si
par exemple
j'exerce un certain pouvoir et qu'en
face de moi j'ai un point un pouvoir
exercé par un homme
et bien il ne sera pas exercer de la
même manière la différence entre nous
sera une sorte de correcteurs à 2 à des
abus possibles bon maintenant il faut
bien savoir que les femmes sont prises
dans des dans des positions genre et de
ce que c'est qu'une femme
bon c'est à dire que l'on considère
qu'une femme doit être 12 persuasi
le secondaire jamais agressive et que
c'était bon et ça ce sont des traits
culturels qui nous ont été inculquées
depuis des générations et il est bien
possible que cela change
avec l'accession aux responsabilités par
des femmes
donc je ne me hasarderai pas à dire que
le pouvoir exercé par des femmes
seraient profondément différents
structurellement différents il ne serait
probablement pendant une ou deux
générations et peut-être que ça
s'estomperait dans le temps mais en tout
cas pour le moment
oui si les femmes exerçait un pouvoir
je crois qu'elle serait et ce sera un
pouvoir différent parce que je crois que
il serait beaucoup plus dans l' écoute
et dans le partage c'est ma conviction
qu'elle guide spirituel peut être une
femme
ah ça pourrait être ce sont des guides
spirituels merveilleux je crois que
effectivement ce qui me concerne je ne
veux pas parler pour les autres
en ce qui me concerne j'aime écouter
j'aime sentir l'intériorité de quelqu'un
j'aime sentir ses mouvements j'aime voir
sa conscience se déplacer et ses idées
évolué et il aime sentir surtout et que
cette personne est habité par la
présence du seigneur parce que dieu
habite en chacun de nous et approcher au
plus près de cette présence divine dans
l'être humain c'est pour moi quelque
chose d'extraordinaire je ne sais pas si
c'est super si physique spécifiquement
féminins mais je sais que moi j'aimerais
exercer c'est quand je le peux je le
fais avec beaucoup de satisfaction et d'
enthousiasme au foot ou même pouvoir
être pacsé ce que vous avez écrit une
femme pape qu'est ce que ça pourrait
changer
écoutez prenez un beau vêtement blanc
prenez une calotte et mettez un visage
de femme et vous verrez tout de suite la
différence
moi je la vois je vois en ce moment une
femme souriante vêtue d'une
soutane blanche avec une calotte et je
la vois au balcon de la place saint
pierre et pour moi c'est très
réjouissant et ça parle tout seul
vous êtes bibliste je le rappelle que
vous a appris la lecture de la bible
dans le rapport aux femmes
à la lecture de la bible m'a appris
énormément
la bible est un livre qui ne fait pas la
morale qui raconte l'histoire d'un
peuple avec ses errements avec ses bons
et ses mauvais moment et sur les femmes
en particulier
j'ai appris que jésus les traités
exactement de la même manière
jamais il n'a fait ce qu'on appelle
acceptions de sexe si jamais il était
traité différemment
il les a traités comme des êtres humains
à part entière et je crois que ma
légitimité de femmes catholiques je la
tiens de ce regard de jésus sur les
femmes
y a rien à dire de plus merci beaucoup
anne soupa pour cet entretien on suivra
avec attention l'évolution de votre
candidature à l'archevêché de lyon merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver cette grande interview sur
notre site internet arte france un point
tv à plus tard
[Musique]